in other news we turn to the growing
crisis at the u.s mexico border where
the number of migrant children in border
patrol custody
has soared and cbs news has learned 4
200 unaccompanied kids are now being
held
most longer than they should be legally
speaking the biden administration
has ordered fema to help with the surge
and a group of republican lawmakers is
headed to the border to
headed to the border today to draw
attention to the problem wishes
joins us now from the white house wisha
good morning to you fema is normally
associated with things like hurricane
response
why they being called in now good
morning tony fema
is providing immediate relief just like
they would during a disaster to the
children
including food water and basic medical
needs they're also setting up
long-term shelters as you mentioned by
law these kids are supposed to be
transferred out of short-term facilities
within 72 hours but lawyers for some of
them tell cbs news
that they were held for as long as seven
days that they were hungry
and never saw the sun these images from
a few days ago
show young migrants arriving to the
southern border
because of a lack of space at long-term
shelters
due in part to covid restrictions
thousands are being held in short-term
facilities
according to government records reviewed
by cbs
news democrats blame the trump
administration
what we are seeing today is the
consequence of
four years of dismantling every system
and place
to address this with humanity and
compassion but after plummeting in 2020
the number of migrant children in u.s
custody has
surged since january is the biden
open border policies that are inviting
even more illegal immigration president
biden's coordinator for the southern
border
seemed to acknowledge a change in the
white house may have had an
impact surges tend to respond to
hope and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
craig fugate was the administrator of
fema in the obama
administration in 2014 he helped manage
a similar surge of unaccompanied minors
is there anything more they could have
done
to be better prepared to handle the
surge
it was going to be one of the challenges
we knew early on what are the numbers
what's the intel look like
uh so i think that's part of the reason
why fema was asked to step
in is to help speed this process up
allow the agencies to get caught up with
the children
and then build a system that would then
be able to surge
and move faster through the system
back in 2014 then vice president biden
travel to central american countries to
send the message to migrants
not to come the white house says that is
the message now though there are no
plans
yet for the president to travel to the
area however
a group of senior administration
officials led by the homeland security
secretary was already there
and briefed president biden
we just thank you